welcome to Leeds University to the
pyramid canteen for a special program
looking at possible ways forward its
pregs it crisis Deal or No Deal this was
a politician free zone ahead of another
big week in Westminster so we brought
together a group of people from across
Leeds a city split in the referendum to
ask what they think should happen next
and they didn't hold back we've got a
political class that are refusing to
listen to a Democratic majority and vote
the vote was taken we instructed them
they should obey our wishes people will
adapt and overcome that's what they do
you you know I will still get up and go
to work on the 30th of March everyone in
this room will do exactly what they were
going to do individual motivation won't
change so but bill just carry on some
people think no deal means status quo it
doesn't so we know we've got a lot of
work to do as companyís to just say that
actually that is not what it means at
all it's not we're not just gonna remain
we may as well
revoke article 50 now give us some time
to find a deal that works for everyone
because we don't have a united country
and by leaving on state after march but
actually not healing the divide one of
the most contentious issues whether a
second referendum should be held who
risk disengaging a large portion of the
country that took part in this
referendum that have never engaged in
political for what is democracy without
facts the people didn't know everything
that was going on we voted to leave and
the political class is like oh but we
don't want to leave and all they've done
for two-and-a-half years is try and
undermine that vote and try and overturn
it well second referendum supporters
need to aknowledge is there's just
nowhere that a second referendum could
be democratically valid because there'd
be millions and millions of leave as
such as myself who wouldn't see it as
valid and wouldn't participate in it
what was fascinating about this debate
is that the opinions here in this room
pretty much represented the opinions
across the nation but if there is unity
across these divides it's this that many
people now want their politicians to get
on with the job and bring some
conclusion to brexit a new week we'll
see a new plan put before Parliament but
if this group of people is anything to
go by patience in politics is running
out Nick Martin Sky News leads